the republican national committee
is now
joining
donald trump and others
in desperately trying to keep their own
email records away from the january 6
committee investigating the trump riots
of 2021. once again this is not the
behavior of parties who have nothing to
hide
cnn report rnc tries to stop 2020 email
communications data from going to the
january 6th committee on wednesday the
house select committee investigating the
attack on the u.s capitol is poised to
receive data from the republican party's
email communications platform salesforce
and the republican national committee
rushed to court last night to try to
block it
the development is the latest to emerge
about the house's aggressive pursuits
reconstructing political misinformation
after the 2020 election that contributed
to trump supporters storming the capital
on january 6th
the rnc alleges that the house
subpoenaed a sales force seeking
information about election
communications including those related
to former president trump quote would
give the select committee unprecedented
access to the rnc's internal political
strategies and to private personal
information regarding supporters
practically adding reasons that their
emails should be investigated what were
they telling their big donors
right on the eve
of the january 6th trump riots political
strategies which they want to hide are
exactly what got these people where they
are now political strategies that
involve lying about election results
intimidation calling for violence
spreading fear and propaganda through
right-wing media trying to invalidate
voters purge voter rolls change vote
totals send alternate bogus slates of
electors all of those things are why
we're in this mess
and so the january 6th committee is 100
percent right to say hey maybe they were
talking about that stuff in their email
communications and if there isn't
illegal stuff in there they don't really
have anything to worry about i mean
everybody knows what the strategies are
you think we're going to learn about new
strategies by looking at their emails we
know what the strategies are what we
might learn is that they were openly
plotting and communicating about them
with donors and other higher-ups
the article goes on last week the rnc
filed a lawsuit against the house
committee
complaining about the sales force
salesforce subpoena's breath
but that lawsuit was unlikely to succeed
as it was aimed only at the committee
not at salesforce and there is no
emergency mechanism to fast track it in
court so salesforce was planning to turn
these records over
but now the rnc has added sales force to
the lawsuit will they uh ultimately get
those records i don't know we'll find
out you know very soon but think of the
irony and think of the hypocrisy and the
double standard
the dnc emails were hacked you might
remember that
and uh putin told trump very strongly
that it wasn't russia and trump believed
him okay whatever but the dnc emails
were hacked
and of course
republicans didn't take the high road
they didn't they didn't say these were
incorrectly released we're not going to
use them they immediately use those
emails for propaganda and here
they are saying well no no no no no it
would be completely improper we're not
talking about hacking we're but they're
acting as though
this legal mechanism is worse than the
hacking you're like no no no it would be
inappropriate to use that legal
mechanism to get these documents from us
and the documents shouldn't shouldn't be
released that would be wrong
but when documents were hacked they were
fine to use them and publicize them etc
etc and this is to be fair to be fair
both sides do this not to the same
degree but both sides when there are
documents that are
made public
if you don't like the content of the
documents you focus on the impropriety
of them being made public
if you like the content of the documents
you just focus on the content democrats
and republicans they all do this but
they're not as hypocritical to this
degree if they did nothing wrong they
should have nothing to hide and it's
more than that they should want to clear
themselves of any wrongdoing
even if their strategy gets out to the
committee
they should be eager to prove we were
not involved in anything untoward or
potentially against the law now what do
i think is potentially going to be
exposed by these documents if they are
released on today's bonus show we're
going to talk about what's going on with
supreme court justice clarence thomas's
wife jenny thomas jenny thomas we now
have learned attended uh one of the
january 6th events she attended the
january 6 rally before the attack she
wasn't at the attack but she was at the
rally before the attack and clarence
thomas thomas has recently been making
statements about we don't want the
supreme court to become political
i am
suspicious
that part of what is now the kind of
next ring in these concentric circles
around the trump riots is something that
relates to ginny thomas and thus has the
potential to pull in clarence thomas and
we're going to talk about that a lot
more uh on today's bonus show they've
gotten away with a lot of shenanigans
for a very long time
and uh the the january 6 committee is
right to go after these email
communications and let's hope that they
get them
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping